nine goals on the season he'll get another chance
against McLoud steps in out and a shot F off by
Alex blassic we had a little incident with him
and our own Jean Principe that I'm sure we'll
share with you later on some you guys talking to
him this morning here's Bard off the stretch quick
shot he scores over the left shoulder of Stuart
Skinner and Conor Bard has his 12th of the Year
Chicago strikes first it's one nothing and one of
the men they came to see is on the board how fast
he can get this Puck off not only the quickness
the power but the accuracy takes the outlet pass
goes underneath the sticker that K who cloes
quick so it looks like he has him pushes him to
the backand but he brings it backand to forehand
it's a lightning fast release watch this forehead
back up over top of the glove is steuart Skinner
the point from the outlet pass the defensive Zone
sends Bard in well that time he didn't need it to
be loaded at all a cloud with control the puck for
Ev and a blast by C sa Ric a rebound loose and
just sitting outside the blue paint controlled
by Evan buar whipped up the right hand side mcav
cuts in shoots and that was a GL save for Peter
barzik similar type of release head to-head there
again so we're going to watch for that match up
and already Luke Richardson has thrown a different
line on the ice beaten off the draw shot deflected
off the side of the net hman crowd thought it was
in it clipped the side of the net off the midair
Swipe by Zack Hyman drop off and fed Down Low by
Crevier who by the way picked up a second assist
on the goal scored by Bard and now a centering
pass wide open Felino denied Point Blank by Stuart
Skinner with nearly 8 minutes gone by the key is
they've got w minutes out of Joey Anderson the
third member of that line and really a journeyman
was kind of bounced around lead pass left hand
side brid shot off the run the P made by Peter
marzik against the activating Brett kulak Kenny de
AR off his back foot radish cross I Conor Murphy
steps up shot from Distance by Johnson kicked out
by Skinner Johnson of course three Stanley Cup
finals two championships with Tampa Warren Fogle
working in went down thought he was high stick two
on one Johnson the trailer bili and then radish
couldn't finish turned into a three-on-one radish
put it in front came right back at him CC and
brown help him out all of a sudden Dr cyle breaks
free tracked by zeit said the veteran here's Kane
a shot F off by morazzi who again has been red hot
at one point Lou stopped 86 shots in a row KF left
wing and that's grabbed up high by goenda W on the
puck turned it over Evan brard the steel the clear
to Center Newen Hopkins rolls itead for McDavid
back in front Newen Hopkins scores the time
goal his six from McDavid and Edmonson caught
Chicago in a matchup the Hawks don't want any
part of just a little backand sauce onto the tape
right here he takes this out the PASS gives it to
McDavid he knows he has a speed you can see both
guys watching McDavid on the entry into the Zone
both Hawk players it leaves Ryan nen Hopkins open
a beautiful little pass onto his tape and then
the quick backand to forehand elevation up over
top of the blocker Dickson trying to create for
Felina who's got the puck rifles along the ice get
kicked it out the outlet to Derek Ry and he's able
to fight right through Phillips long at the puck
mury broke it up a steal by Phillips sent ahead
for felo he'll gain the line oh beautiful try
move around D going to be stopped on the backand
by Stewart Skinner some move by F long time
Captain Columbus fought off by the leather of
skner off the dump Skinner up the right hand side
Brown fighting through traffic Le on dry CLE with
Kane shoots this time and rozik slides to his
right to make a Nifty save R's had some looks
he liked at the pass in the first two-on one
he had earlier in this period This Time takes
a real good look but it's the hustle to
get to that puck it's bouncing he steals
you played your 400th game in Chicago oh here's
a man who fell down Dickson with an opportunity
rifles on that the save Skinner so that's 15
16 17 turning 18y old year pretty impressive
there's 20-year-old in that LE quick steal and
a denial of Tyler Johnson by Stuart Skinner we
were talking about earlier and whistle stumbles
bumps it away from McLoud but CeCe will jump up
on this Puck shoot it and a sa made by Peter
morz and defend you a little more aggressively
make him track back make him play around their
neck and you said that from the top of the show
you felt the four check would be key here's
kulak trying to finish the check with derck
Ryan support in front stor right on Q Sam G
makes it 21 Edmonton as the Oilers do go to
work and convert what a beautiful little pass
and a beautiful finish from Sam G you mentioned
it kolak the defensive says you know what I got
some Wheels he gets in finishes the check that
doesn't allow gr to get this Puck out of the
Zone second support great job by Derek Ryan
to fist this Puck out of the back hand F guard
but this is where the orders will have success
I know they've scored on a transitional goal
but it was with speed in all eight goals that
night Inc night just unbelievable 84 was the final
got a call from Gretzky after shot by Murphy from
distance blink you mean here's McDavid dropping
it off who back to McDavid in front back H and
N what a save made by Peter mzik and that
was a terrific look I think was surprised
that pu bounced out to him absolutely Stone
Zack I mean just monsters in Kier had a good
conversation with him this morning talking
about watching how gills a younger the back
growing up and for the Canadians and also
Brandon Carlo for Boston he said he was
a guy that he really studied and wanted to
play the way he plays Leon tridle deflected
off the Stick of sight have it in and Edmonton
catches a break for a 3-1 lead that's 12 for
drle little chip into the zone at the for check
by Fogle just talked about it win a puck battle
it'll blow of a wheel in front of the net by dry
CLE but it's the secondary person that comes in
G keeps the play alive and as he tries to go back
to G back door right-handed shot goes off a Zev it
was a real good attempt if you look you're going
to see G kind of come into the picture don't for
that one new Hopkins to drop it back for Bard
Leandra smack one in off Z in the second period
and now a deple by hman from McDavid perfectly
executed no chance braic 4-1 Edmonton on Hyman's
team leading 16 the shot mentality of McDavid
early on in the power play a couple of shots
gets the box to settle in and they're really not
looking to pressure they're just trying to take
cross scene passes away but what that allows is
M to be a little more aggressive and he takes
the outside the inside around Felino and then
the perfect pass through Conor Murphy right to
the tape of Zack special teams in goaling now
a man slips Conor Brown looking for his first
of the year that shot stayed out lard slip Brown
again and that one glistened off the goal post I
believe that might have kissed iron nice drop
by it whistle but it's neutralized by McDavid
backtracking and H's able to squeeze around
Phillips head to the net shot and that's held
by mazik and this will be the seventh time in
eight games the Oilers hold an opponent 27 shots
or less they win going away 4 to one Bard has
the game's first goal but Edmonton the next more